what we have here we can view as the
long-run equilibrium or long-run the
steady-state for a perfectly competitive
market let's say this is the market for
apples and it was this idealized
perfectly competitive situation where
you have many firms producing their non
differentiated they have the same cost
structure there's no barriers to entry
or exit and on the left you can see that
this equilibrium price which is set by
the intersection of the supply and
demand curves that that's just going to
be the the price that the firm's have to
take and we've talked about that at
length in other videos that's going to
define that the firm's marginal revenue
not just this firm but all of the
participants in the market in other
videos we've talked about the fact that
the rational quantity for this firm to
produce would be where marginal revenue
intersects marginal cost and it's also
going to be the point where you have
zero economic profit where at that
quantity let's say the quantity for the
firm your average total cost is equal to
your marginal revenue if marginal
revenue were higher than average total
cost at this quantity well then you
would have other entrants into the
market because you're having positive
economic profit if marginal revenue is
below average total cost at that
quantity
well then firms are running economic
losses and you will have people exiting
the industry and either of those
situations would get us back to an
equilibrium state that looks something
like this but now let's imagine a shock
to the market somehow let's say a new
research study comes out that says that
this the apples that this market
produces that it's incredibly good for
you like you live longer it'll make you
happier it'll make you have more friends
well then the demand for apples goes up
and so you have a new demand curve that
looks something like this D prime well
in that situation what's going to happen
well now you have a new equilibrium
price you also have a new equilibrium
quantity over here let's call that P
prime this is going to define a new
marginal revenue curve for the
participants in the industry so M
marginal revenue prime and now all of a
sudden the rational quantity for them to
produce would be out here at least for
this firm to be to produce so Q prime
for this firm is out here and you notice
at that quantity it is making economic
profit for every unit
gets that much it costs that much on
average for every unit so it's making
that much per unit and then you multiply
that times the number of units of the
quantity this whole area is going to be
the economic profit that this firm is
getting and it's likely that all of the
firm's were most of the firm's in this
perfectly competitive market are going
to be getting it because they all have
the same cost structure but as we've
said before when you have this positive
economic profit and there's no barriers
to entry in the long run more firms will
enter because there's economic profit to
be had and in previous videos we talked
about a situation where as firms enter
into a market or exited market it
doesn't change the cost structures of
the individual firms but let's imagine
for a second that because of everyone
entering into this market that seems to
have economic profit for the firms that
are participating into it some of the
inputs of say growing apples which is
what these firms do start to go up in
cost so we're not talking about constant
costs perfectly competitive market now
we're not talking about an increasing
cost perfectly competitive market well
then firm a and every firm's cost
structure is going to change because as
more firms come in you're going to have
to pay more for maybe apple seeds pay
more for maybe pesticides or wax or
maybe pay more for a land on which to
grow them and so you would have a
different marginal cost curve maybe the
marginal cost curve now looks like this
so marginal cost curve prime you would
also have a new average total cost curve
maybe it looks maybe it looks something
like this so average total cost prime
and so you could imagine that firms will
jump into the market in order to capture
or think that they might be able to get
some economic profit but they will only
do so until the economic profit for all
the firms goes to zero so what point
will the economic profit go to zero well
that's when the marginal revenue for the
firm's is equal to our marginal cost is
equal to our average total cost so it's
that point right over there
so we would get to this point right over
here let's call that marginal revenue
prime and so more and more firms would
enter to the market up until the point
that the equilibrium price gets us to P
Prime and so the supply would increase
those folks want to get that economic
profit but it would increase until
this point so it shift a little bit to
the right and we would get to s Prime as
you can see based on this we can now
start to imagine a long-run supply curve
in this increasing cost perfectly
competitive market we were over here
that was an equilibrium point before now
we are over here and so our long-run
supply curve in this increasing cost
environment even though it's perfectly
competitive might look something like
this so the constant cost world this was
a flat line now in an increasing cost
world as more and more people enter the
market the cost structure the inputs
into producing an apple go up now
long-run supply is that remember of the
long run is enough time to go by for
people to enter and exit the market or
enough time to go by so fixed costs
don't aren't fixed anymore that they can
be shed or that they could be increased
now you could do another thought
exercise let's say we're dealing with a
market where the more people that enter
the market the inputs actually get
cheaper and if that seems hard to
believe you could imagine well now
people are able to produce seeds or wax
at a new scale so the inputs actually
get cheaper well then you would see the
opposite thing then you would see that
as more entrance into the market this
cost structure goes down and so the
supply can increase more and more and
more and more to point that the
equilibrium price is now lower than it
was before and then you would have a
downward sloping long-run supply curve